in the past if you if you're a designer
yourself for example young and the
preneur and you want to build a hardware
product you need to rely on outsourcing
companies providing you with prototypes
or you know manufacturing plans
facilities and now you can do it
in-house so you basically can come when
you have an idea you can create it in a
matter of hours and not in a matter of
days my name is Michael Sorkin I'm 27
years old I'm from Germany Berlin and
the co-founder and chairman of I go 3d I
think I'm a maker myself to a certain
degree but mostly I wouldn't consider
myself an engineer so I'm trying to
connect the post words making things and
building up companies and my company is
helping you know young disruptive
companies in 3d printing technology and
to the markets especially in Europe the
best way to describe it is a roller
coaster or we started in 2010 where the
patents run out for the core
technologies and you know it was crazy
we went through 3d printed guns 3d
printed organs over you know 3d printed
sex toys in the most extreme cases now
the industry is more saddling and you
know the hype is lowering fading out and
it's now coming towards you know real
practical applications I was born in
Russia I left half my life in Moscow and
moved by the age of 12 to Germany and
since then spends I think in the last 10
years been living in eight different
cities Jimmy so I learned the language
quite fast it was an interesting
contrast of going from you know from
Russia to Germany from from Russia to
Europe understanding different
mentalities but I very much prefer being
here when I have started studying
Germany quite a good university but was
really not hands-on at all I was really
you know frustrated with that and I
wanted to build things I want to do
stuff and I started doing it on my aunt
in in the garage or basically in the
basement it was a couple of couponers
and this is how it evolved you know more
or less self driven it's difficult to
say why it matters I think the best way
to describe is again like we're
disrupting the way how people innovate
around the world so basically the entire
manufacturing change supply chains
everything is being changed with or
disrupted with 3d printers I think the
future of 3d printing
is going into the medical market and
into the food market besides the
manufacturing industry
[Music]